ce chat
il
participant frappé dans leurs mains pour
se réchauffer et fait taire hanouka la
fête des lignes symbole pour la
communauté juive de la lumière sur
l'obscurité ils étaient environ 70
personnes jeudi soir dans le quartier de
la gare de montigny le bretonneux ont ce
rassemblement historique à la
température très chaleureux la fête des
lumières est né dans l'antiquité sous
alexandre le grand jérusalem est alors
occupée et se voient imposer la culture
grecque
après avoir résisté la communauté juive
souhaite rallumer le chandelier à sept
branches symbole de la lumière divine
dans ce mur c'est important pour moi de
te dis parce que c'est une fête qui est
quand même très très importante dans la
communauté juive
c'est la fête des lumières donc voilà
c'est aussi pour le rassemblement on se
retrouve tous un petit peu ici parce que
avec les dix privée de chacun et les
horaires de chacun sait pas forcément
facile de soir la lumière l'emportent
toujours l'oppression l'intolérance ne
peut pas vaincre
c'est au contraire cette volonté de
rester soi-même dans la fraternité dans
l'harmonie avec les autres qu'il a un
petit l'emportent
et c'est justement ce que veulent dire
ces flammes et ses lumières qu'on allume
la nuit une lueur d'espoir qui
espéraient également transmettre samuel
sandler dont le fils et les deux petits
enfants sont mortes dans la tuerie de
toulouse perpétrés par mohamed merah en
mars 2012 dans la pensée juive
l'inestimable valeur de la vie c'est
pour tomber aussi face à la déclaration
si souvent reprise d'un célèbre
philosophe français
l'enfer c'est les autres la pensée juive
dans cl inverse à savoir c'est le fait
d'être privé de tout moyen de prodiguer
quoi que ce soit aux autres qui
s'assimile au pire des supplices des
mots
issue du livre de son fils jonathan pour
plus de luminaires